[Musik]
Barbecue von Sebastian raucht der Kopf
er baut den McDonald's Klassiker McRib
nach und deckt auf woher das Raucharoma
aus der Soße des Burgers kommt das hat
sowas animalisches das ist ja irgendwie
so ja
das ist so Qualm außerdem erfahrt ihr
warum der McDonald's Kassenschlager in
Deutschland gar nicht als Bürger
durchgeht
[Musik]
grillen ist doch was schönes ist
glühende Kohlen raucht der aufsteigt und
dieser spezielle Rauchgeschmack im
Fleisch die hier brauchen kein
Holzkohlegrill haben aber trotzdem auch
Geschmack und wie die das schaffen
jetzt
der McRib steht bei McDonald's für
amerikanisches Barbecue in der Werbung
taucht saftiges Fleisch in herzhafte
Soße
ist ein Topseller der größten Burger
Kette der Welt das Produkt erinnert an
Spareribs im Original sind das die
Rippen aus dem Schweinebauch sie werden
am Knochen gegrillt für volles Aroma
auf dem McRib von McDonald's liegt
tatsächlich ein langes Stück Fleisch nur
wurde hier nichts gegrillt Sebastian
lege deckt auf was wirklich in dem
Fastfood steckt na Lust auf dem McRib
komm den haben sie alle schon mal
gegessen und wo das Ding rauskam hat
jeder gedacht oh lecker
Rippchen mal sehen Sie keine Rippchen
natürlich nicht wer viel zu aufwendig in
der Produktion Sebastian lege baut den
legendären Burger von McDonald's nach er
setzt auf fettiges Schweinefleisch im
ersten Schritt stellt er im Fleischwolf
selber Hack her
gewolft ist alles jetzt brauchen wir
Bindung
Bindung entsteht mit Hilfe von
salzsäuerungsmittel und Eiswürfeln
[Musik]
kann losgehen
der Produktentwickler hat aus einem
leeren Bierfass eine
fleisch-waschmaschine gebastelt ein
Tumblr Marke Eigenbau
durch die Bewegung verbinden sich die
Eiweiße die Masse klebt zusammen
[Musik]
tammler aus und Ruhe perfekt die Bindung
Bindung erhöht die Bissfestigkeit das
Schweinehack soll später im Mund an
Rippchen erinnern richtig schöne Bindung
perfekt genauso muss es sein und hier ja
das ist eine händische formmaschine zack
zack
machen wir mal den ersten probieren wir
es mal
wichtig ist hier keine Lufteinschlüsse
deswegen wir müssen es ruckartig
reinschlagen damit die Luft entweichen
kann dann bitte noch leicht verpresst
und dann ist fertig
in Form gepresst sieht das Hackfleisch
ein wenig aus wie echtes
wegen der vielen Zutaten geht der McRib
in Deutschland gar nicht als Burger
ein Hamburger darf hierzulande nur
Rindfleisch Salz und Gewürze enthalten
[Musik]
und dann wird der Burger gemacht
seinen Geschmack bekommt der McRib ganz
allein durch die spezielle Soße erst sie
bringt typischen Grillgeschmack ins
Fleisch für diesen Nachbau greift
Sebastian lege tief in seine Trickkiste
die Soße macht die Party
ganz schön viele Zutaten oder alles
beginnt mit Wasser Salz und Zucker für
den Geschmack sorgen verschiedene
Gewürzpulver dazu kommen mehrere
Bindemittel
Tomatenmark bringt Farbe in die Soße die
geformten Fleischstücke sollen später
auch nach Grill schmecken und dann kommt
noch wirklich der Star in der Western
Soße Raucher
ohne Rauch keine westernsoße also ohne
Qualm keine Schießerei vom Saloon
und wie die das Schaffen in der Fabrik
den Rauch hier im flüssiger Form her zu
stellen das schauen wir uns an kommen
Sie mal mit
Bodenfelde in Niedersachsen hier sitzt
die Firma proFagus sie ist Europas
größter Hersteller für Raucharoma
Sebastian lege schaut sich an wie das
aus Holz gewonnen wird den Geruch nimmt
man ja hier schon kilometerweit nimmt
man den ja schon war oder das ist
richtig das fühlt sich so fühlt sich
Heimat bei uns an das Unternehmen stellt
hauptsächlich Grillkohle und Briketts
her an Nebenprodukt ist Raucharoma
interessieren würde wie viel Liter
raucherober produziert ihr im Jahr wir
machen so momentan etwas mehr als 1000
Tonnen das heißt das sind ungefähr 1
Million Liter die wir hier im Jahr
herstellen Sebastian lege packt an die
Firma nutzt Buchenholz das wird gelagert
in kleine Stücke gehackt und getrocknet
aus dem Holzscheiten soll Raucharoma
werden
[Musik]
Radlader
über vorderanlagen wandert das Holz in
die verkohlungsanlage das Herzstück ist
die sogenannte Reporte ein riesiger
Stahlbehälter
[Musik]
Arbeiter tragen feuerfeste
Schutzkleidung die Maschinen sind extrem
heiß Gase und Tiere entweichen es riecht
intensiv nach brennendem Holz das hat
sowas animalisches das ist ja irgendwie
so ja
das ist so Qualm und ich liebe das genau
meine Welt
aus dem Holz entweicht durch die Hitze
Rauch der Rauch wird abgesaugt und in
Wasser eingeleitet
dadurch kondensiert er und wird flüssig
sogenannter Liquid smoke entsteht dieser
wird in seine verschiedenen Bestandteile
zerlegt und schließlich gefiltert und
gereinigt
Sebastian lege bekommt jetzt sein
Raucharoma er kann die verschiedenen
gewonnenen Substanzen je nach Wunsch
zusammen mixen
die Mission den McRib im Duft und
Geschmack nachempfinden
ah so langsam sehe ich mich schon im
McDrive i'm a grippal schön guten Tag
Ihre Bestellung einmal Raucher Roma
dieses Aroma kann Sebastian Nägel jetzt
in seinen McRib Nachbau geben gemischt
nach dem Vorbild McDonald's
Raucharoma ersetzt bei McRib offenes
Feuer das gewürzte Schweinehack landet
im Fast Food später nur auf dem
edelstahlherd
so
dass ein bisschen Röstaromen steht
damit später die Soße mit dem Raucharoma
komplett in das Fleisch einziehen kann
werden die in der Soße zu Ende gegart so
das wird zugemacht
und wird ganz langsam in der Soße gar
gezogen so dass sie Soße sich richtig an
das Patty haften kann und wir später
diesen Genuss haben als wären wir auf
einer richtig schönen amerikanischen
Barbecue Party
McDonalds insider berichten die Patties
liegen bis zu 90 Minuten in der Soße
damit Sie sich richtig mit Raucharoma
voll saugen
[Musik]
genau so soll er aussehen hier
ja perfekt so na wer von ihnen hat sich
damit auch schon mal die Klamotten
eingesaut ich auf alle Fälle paar
Zwiebeln drauf
Deckel
und fertig ist der McRib und das ganze
ohne Grill ohne Kohle aber trotzdem mit
rauchigen Geschmack
wow
Produktentwickler Sebastian lege ist der
Nachbau gelungen
[Musik]
gerade oh lecker
Raucharoma erspart McDonald's
[Musik]
schädlich aber natürlich sorgen sie
durch ihren intensiven Geschmack dafür
dass Produkte die vielleicht qualitativ
und geschmacklich nicht so toll sind
sehr stark aufgewertet werden
Schweinehack mit Raucharoma beim McRib
ergibt das ein Grillerlebnis
eine geniale Geschäftsidee von
McDonald's
[Applaus]